in 1982 a series of events in and around
Chicago transformed consumer safety on
the morning of September 29
twelve-year-old Mary Kellerman told her
parents she wasn't feeling well so they
gave her an extra strength Tylenol
capsule immediately after Mary collapsed
she was dead by 10 am
that same day postal worker Adam Giannis
came down with a cold he purchased some
extra strength Tylenol at a supermarket
he took two capsules and immediately
went into convulsions he later died in
hospital
doctors suspected that the 27 year old
had a heart attack
after grieving at the hospital Adams
Family came together at his home to
comfort his wife and two small children
his brother Stanley was so
grief-stricken he came down with a
headache he grabbed some Tylenol from
the same bottle Adam had purchased
earlier that day
he offered some to his newly wedded wife
Teresa they took two capsules each soon
after they collapsed Stanley died that
day Teresa held on for two more days
before passing away
the unusual deaths caught the attention
of firefighters from the affected
suburbs of Chicago firefighter Richard
keyworth said this is a wild stab but
maybe it's Tylenol another firefighter
who had the same suspicions reached out
to a nurse from the local community
nurse Helen Jensen spoke to Adam
giannis's Widow and realized all three
family members had taken Tylenol she
thought it has to be the Tylenol but she
said the medical examiner and police
didn't believe her and even laughed it
off
in another suburb of Chicago Mary Reiner
was feeling woozy she had given birth to
her fourth child two days earlier the
hospital gave her some Tylenol to help
with her postpartum recovery and she
also purchased some from a store
immediately after taking two capsules
she felt dizzy and collapsed Mary died
the following day at the same hospital
where she had just given birth
another Mary Mary McFarland was taking a
dinner break in the shopping center
where she worked the 31 year old single
mom had a migraine she took two Tylenol
capsules and minutes later collapsed she
never regained consciousness
that evening flight attendant Paula
Prince landed at Chicago's O'Hare
International Airport after a long day
she stopped at a Walgreens on her way
home an ATM surveillance camera captured
the 35 year old purchasing the pills
that would kill her
when she failed to show up for work her
sister and a colleague went to her
apartment and found her lifeless body
all seven people died after taking
Tylenol when an investigator with the
medical examiner's office first examined
the Tylenol bottle for Mary Kellerman's
house and the other from the onuses they
smelled like bitter almonds The Examiner
knew instantly what he was dealing with
the odor was cyanide
he was lucky to catch a whiff of cyanide
because only about 60 percent of the
population can detect the bitter almond
scent out of the 44 remaining capsules
in the yannis's bottle four were found
to contain cyanide each capsule had
between 550 to 610 milligrams of
potassium cyanide nearly three times the
amount needed to kill someone their
blood samples tested positive for
cyanide poisoning a dodged reporter
named John Flynn Rooney received a tip
and broke the story of the poisonings
before an official news conference was
called
stores began pulling pain relievers off
the shelves Chicago Police drove through
the streets using loudspeakers to order
people to flush Tylenol down the toilet
these actions likely saved more lives as
no further deaths occurred finding the
person responsible however would not
happen so quickly
the corporation that owned Tylenol
Johnson and Johnson did not think this
was the work of an employee he believed
the capsules were laced with cyanide
after leaving the factories because the
poison capsules came from multiple
manufacturing plants investigators
believed someone must have taken the
bottles off store shelves pulled the two
casings apart lace them with poison and
then reattach the halves before
returning them to the store the capsule
on the left is regular Tylenol the
capsule on the right contains cyanide
the powder is off-white in grayish in
color and lumpier store management
pulled all the Tylenol off the shelves
on Thursday the poisonings were the
biggest story in the country
oh we've been receiving calls about once
every 15 seconds Tylenol was the most
popular pain reliever in America extra
strength Tylenol aspirin free and you
can't buy a more potent pain reliever
without a prescription Tylenol
controlled 37 of the over-the-counter
pain reliever market and accounted for
400 million in sales the year before
after the deaths tylenol's market share
plummeted to seven percent Johnson and
Johnson recalled all 31 million bottles
of Tylenol capsules more tainted
capsules were found fortunately they had
not been sold or consumed the poisonings
changed how over-the-counter drugs were
packaged at the time there was no
protective ceiling on any
over-the-counter drug bottles Johnson
and Johnson worked with the FDA to
include safety seals which became the
norm for packaged food as well the
company also introduced a new version of
its pill the caplet which was harder to
tamper with than the older capsules a
few years later Tylenol stopped selling
its capsule version for good Johnson and
Johnson spent 100 million on the recall
and relaunch of Tylenol and it was worth
it within a year Tylenol seals bounced
back and once again became America's
favorite over-the-counter pain reliever
but for the families of the victims
there was no relief from their pain
police had not caught the person
responsible for the deaths of their
loved ones but they did have someone in
mind about a week after the poisonings
tylenol's manufacturer McNeil a
subsidiary of Johnson and Johnson
received a letter in the mail inside was
a note written in all caps gentlemen as
you can see it is easy to play cyanide
both potassium and sodium into capsules
sitting on store shells if you want to
stop the killing then wire one million
dollars to bank account number eight
four four nine five nine seven at
Continental Illinois Bank Chicago
Illinois
was this really the killer the FBI
discovered that the bank account
mentioned in the note belonged to
Frederick Miller McKay the heir to the
Miller Brewing Fortune however police
didn't believe he wrote the letter the
bank account mentioned in the note had
been closed after McKay shut down his
travel agency the letter was traced to
his agency's Pitney Bowes stamp machine
was the letter writer someone who had
access to the agency and held The Grudge
police learned that one of mckayhi's
former employees Nancy Richardson was
upset that her final paycheck of 511
dollars had bounced Nancy's husband
Robert Richardson had angrily confronted
mckayhee over the check the Pritchard
sins had moved out of Chicago just weeks
before the poisonings when police issued
a warrant for the couple's arrest they
discovered they had been using fake
names Robert and Nancy Richardson were
aliases their real names were James and
Leanne Lewis
authorities track them down in New York
City and arrested James Lewis at the New
York Public Library
fingerprints match those on the
extortion letter sent to Johnson and
Johnson he said he never intended to
collect the cash and was simply trying
to embarrass his wife's former boss
Lewis may have been the letter writer
but was he the Tylenol killer during his
sentencing hearing in the extortion case
he sat down with cbs2 did you commit the
Tylenol murders I did not
do you know who did I I do not know who
did no but investigators were not
convinced some believe Lewis resembled
the man caught on surveillance video
watching flight attendant Paula Prince
purchased the Tylenol capsules
investigators were fortunate to get this
shot because the ATM security camera
only captured still photos when someone
was using the machine
as investigators dug into James Lewis's
background they learned he had a
troubled past and faced a murder charge
when he was a little boy his father
abandoned him then his mother a couple
adopted him at the age of two and raised
him on a farm in Missouri as a teen he
attacked his adoptive mother with an ax
and spent time in a mental institution
he attended the University of Missouri
Kansas City where he met Leanne they
married and had a daughter
Tony Ann was born with Down syndrome and
had other health problems by all
accounts Lewis doted on her an FBI
report stated he never showed anger
about Tony's condition or blamed anyone
the couple opened a tax accounting
business in Kansas City called Lewis and
Lewis one of their clients was an
elderly man named Raymond West West
lived a simple retired life after
working as a truck driver he kept the
rose bushes in front of his home
perfectly pruned and took walks every
day but one day he disappeared
when her friend went to his home to
check on him he found a note taped to
the front door which reads out of town
until Thursday for further call Jim it
was written on Lewis and Lewis
stationery
when West's friend returned to the house
a few weeks later he smelled a foul odor
emanating from a bedroom and called
police when police arrived they looked
in the attic and to their horror found
Raymond West's decomposing body his legs
had been severed police quickly zoned in
on a suspect James Lewis
a West had made out a check to Lewis for
five thousand dollars dated the last day
anyone had heard from him a handwriting
expert concluded the check was likely
forged when police searched Louis's cars
they found dozens of canceled checks
belonging to West they also found a rope
matching the Rope found around West's
body Lewis denied killing West and said
the Rope was from the time he helped
West rebuild his home after the flood a
year before there was plenty of
circumstantial evidence linking Lewis to
the crime and prosecutors charged him
with murder however the case was
dismissed due to a technicality Lewis
should have been read his Miranda rights
before questioning when he was arrested
and brought to the police station this
is the you have the right to remain
silent warning but police never read him
his rights a judge ruled that police
acted improperly in arresting Lewis and
throughout the evidence taken from
Lewis's cars and all the statements he
made to police
prosecutors lost some of their best
circumstantial evidence
there was one other piece of evidence a
fingerprint was found on the pulley used
to hoist West's body into the attic but
police had not been able to match the
print to Lewis
three years later the FBI used
state-of-the-art equipment to confirm
that the fingerprint belonged to Lewis
however Lewis was never recharged with
murder
a reason someone is not charged despite
new evidence is that it might not be
sufficient to meet the burden of proof
required for a conviction
what about the Tylenol murders could
Lewis have been behind those
investigators believed he had a motive
and it had to do with his daughter
Lewis's daughter Tony Ann had a heart
defect that required multiple surgeries
when she was five the suture is used to
repair the hole in her heart tore apart
and she died a federal investigation
later confirmed that the polypropylene
sutures that tore were sold under the
brand name Proline according to records
reviewed by the Chicago Tribune Proline
was produced by Johnson and Johnson the
company that made Tylenol
Lewis blamed the drug manufacturer for
the death of his little girl according
to a police Sergeant quoted in a Memphis
newspaper
he served 13 years for extortion for
writing the ransom letter to Johnson and
Johnson while in prison he produced
elaborate sketches that showed how
cyanide powder could be packed into
capsules but he insisted he was innocent
and was simply trying to help
investigators solve the crime he
explained to the Chicago Tribune I could
tell you how Julius Caesar was killed
but that does not mean I was the Killer
Lewis wasn't the only suspect police
investigated around 400 people including
Roger Arnold who worked in the warehouse
of one of the stores that sold the
tainted Tylenol Arnold also worked with
the father of one of the victims Mary
Reiner who had just given birth
the owner of a bar that Arnold
frequented grew concerned after a couple
of regulars reported that Arnold had
been talking about possessing Cyanide
and working on a project the bar owner
subsequently tipped off police when
Arnold found out he became Furious and
ended up shooting a man he mistakenly
believed was the bar owner the man he
shot a father of three died
and Arnold was sentenced to 30 years in
prison but there was still no one behind
bars for the poisonings
a few weeks after the murders the
Chicago Tribune appealed to the killer
to come forward journalist Bob Green
focused on the suffering of the parents
of young Mary Kellerman
his article read if you are the Tylenol
killer some of this may matter to you
or it may make no difference at all
if you are the Tylenol killer though you
may be harboring just the Vegas
curiosity about the people on the other
end of your plan the people who were
unfortunate enough to purchase the
bottles you had touched
Mary's mother can't have any more
children
Mary was her only baby
you might be interested in knowing that
Mary was born one month premature and
that as she entered the world her mother
was scared because she wasn't crying
but the doctor smiled and said it's all
right she's only sleeping
and she was
she was a quiet child
and because the kellermans knew she
would be their only child she was
especially precious to them
if you are the Tylenol killer you might
want to know that Mary's parents always
consider themselves to be overly
protective
the reason Mary's parents were like that
was that they knew something that a 12
year old girl couldn't know
they knew that the world can at times be
a cruel place and that parents have a
duty to protect their child from dangers
the child might not even know her there
they thought they knew about every
danger that could possibly touch Mary
but they didn't know about you
the letter mentioned that Mary's parents
couldn't bear to visit the cemetery
where their baby girl is buried
investigators hoped the letter would
compel the killer to visit Mary's grave
they kept surveillance on it for months
but the killer never showed
to this day no one has been charged for
the Tylenol killings after the
poisonings some communities ban
trick-or-treating as a precaution
copycat crimes later cropped up but they
were never as widespread or fatal as the
original poisonings nearly 30 years
later James Lewis self-published a book
called Poison the doctor's dilemma it's
a fictional Thriller about a mass
catastrophe in a Midwestern City where
underground water supplies have been
poisoned and people are dying
Lewis has denied any link between his
book and the Tylenol poisonings
it's important to remember that
responsible use of medications in
supplements can be vital to maintaining
your health and well-being for more than
a year I've been supplementing with
magnesium breakthrough as I used to
struggle with falling asleep and staying
asleep I know how important it is to get
a good night's sleep to keep my mind
sharp and productive as I can spend as
much as 12 hours a day every day working
on documentaries like this video that
take a lot of time and effort to put
together I had no clue that 75 percent
of people are magnesium deficient which
can lead to higher levels of anxiety
irritability low energy and trouble
sleeping it's also important to get the
right kind of magnesium that's why I
trust magnesium breakthrough which has
helped me get better sleep and I find I
wake up less tired magnesium
breakthrough is the only organic full
spectrum magnesium supplement that
includes seven unique forms of magnesium
to try it out visit megbreakthrough.com
news things to order and get 10 percent
off with my promo code news think 10. my
custom link is in my description
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm